字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
觀眾朋友注意喔
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
各位同学们大家好
同事长好
大家好 我是主持人Lily
今天是4月13号
大家好
今天台湾股市
创一个收盘价的一个新高
历史新高
很多人觉得说
怎么样
怎么会这样子
今天台湾股市
真的比我想象中强太多了
我本来预测
台湾股市有机会跌400点
那今天连跌400点
只有开盘的时候大概跌两三百点
台子期
那这个看法怎么看
我要告诉大家
等于是就是说
我说的战争已经顿化了
这边已经顿化了
但顿化是顿化的
你要记清楚
顿化是一回事
可是如果持续这个战争打下去的话
应该说持续这个
和母之海峡持续风阻下去的话
迟早会某一天到一个转折
比如说2006年
就有人说是
新东海峡泡沫了
结果到2008年
股市才真正的实现
这个泡沫
所以这个东西
你一定要慢慢的记在脑海里面
现在先假装的酒醉一下
你懂吗
等到
不好意思
我这些喉咙比较怪
等到真正的
确实的影响实体经济的时候
那你到时候要空手
投资朋友
我会到时候带大家
今天本来不想直播的
可没有办法
因为很多人一直敲碗说要直播
所以今天是休息一阵子之后直播
因为之前肺解决的手术
那我已经算是
复活了
复原的非常快了
已经算非常快了
可是其实还是有点累
还是有点累
来
先我们来看一下
来看一下
医生说我已经算复原蛮快的
先我们来看一下
看一下这台湾股市
台湾股市这边
创新高
是真的比我想象中强很多
我投资产不得不承认
算是罕见的
就是说
这一次我算错的蛮厉害的
说老实话
因为我对自己要求蛮高的
我大概在33,000点的时候喊空
那现在台湾股市拉2000多点
看起来我得要翻多了
但是我就会尽量
我会选比较低阶的一个
做多的一个情况
好不好
既然台湾股市那边要下去
那没办法那就可以做多
好不好
做空不成反成多
我还是可以找那种比较低基金的
比如说鸿海
这种股票
在这边股票
来来来跟大家讲
这边低基金的股票
或者准备喷出
你看今天这边股票
投资产你说国际
国际就开始喷了
你别担心
如果它会喷的话
反而上面还有空间
兼带量的上涨
就是我不一定
我买记忆体
我不会主轴主力
这么放在
主轴这么放在记忆体上面
因为你看记忆体
很多股票今天其实没怎么动
它涨的是涨那种
蓝亚科
今天要听说要法说
是啊
如果有法说的话
再跟我们讲
像这种记忆体
这种低基期的股票
你看很多的股票反而不一定有涨
比如说像你说之间创建
还有宇峻
你看
近来大跌5%
有没有
近来大跌
所以有些股票都还在跌
来来
那为什么台湾股市这样会动化
是因为台积电法朔利多
整个大于
这个
和母之海峡的利空
我是有跟大家讲
我说战争还会打下去
和母之海峡还会封锁
注意一下喔
你知道
其中选举是什么时候吗
11月
美国其中选举是11月
那时候其中选举
今天川普直接承认了
就算到那个时候
油价都不一定会下来
哇直接承认了喔
现在4月而已喔
就算到那个时候油价都不会下来
所以陆陆续续的
它一定会影响实体的景气
但是不是现在
什么意思
股市有时候它比较
股市那时候
你不要
你觉得股市有时候领先指标
股市有时候有弱后指标
他等下是真的
哇影响到FED的升降型以后
大家觉得哇这个时候
哇油价高油价真的影响到股市了
才会那时候开始崩
没关系你就是把它放在心里面
所以我要说川普现在已经说
油价高油价会影响到11月
最新消息
还有第二个TOTAL
如果你家里要装还的
你家里是用TOTAL吗
Toto是那个马桶吗
是
好像不是
Toto马桶啊
我们公司
我有一两个马桶是用Toto
是一两个
住不同的地方嘛
好
我是用Toto的
其实现在要用Toto的话
不好意思听说缺货
为什么
因为石化的这些东西
善油都缺货了
现在你要Toto跟他下订单
他拒绝缺货哦
为什么
因为缺乏石油
很多制造業都需要石油
那都影響到了
但是我還是要給您講的是
我現在不需要跟大家講這些東西
因為事實上
台灣股實際上就3萬5千多點了
它就突破個例新高了
那你只要把它放在心裡
就是它的確會影響實體的景氣
你也不要因為這樣子
哇 嘖嘖
那我就覺得我很看很空
你也講得對
那我要去空手
你可以先做多
照說跟我空手嘛
照說再說
我只要告訴你放在心裡
那的確有影響到
韓國股市也有影響到
韓國股市今天是跌的
我們看一下
來
韓國股市今天跌了
0.91
0.8
台灣股市是閃的
很誇張
講一講話我有點喘
不好意思
真的跟大家真的是燃燒生命
在服務大家
來
之前如果一段时间没有操作的
我说我会就送给大家吗
如果都没有操作的话
所以我尽量不会让人家就是吃亏啊
那我们先来看一下
你看
不然我念一下好不好
看得到吗
莉莉
好
战火竟也冲击到马桶
日本偷偷宣布
暫停整體遺浴接單
全原料斷工
可以嗎
念資料不要念錯
好 你再繼續念一下好不好
來
可以再放大一點嗎
來一點點
變私底檢查是不是
下面的
我們標題再講一次好不好
好
戰火鏡也衝擊到馬桶
日本偷偷宣布暫停
暫停整體遺浴接單
全因
沒有關係 全製原料斷工
沒有關係
你這樣講的不順
我來講就好
我們下次再講順一點點 小事小事
來
我本來要喝個水
就是為什麼
因為它用於
鮭魚薄膜連鎖以塗層的材料
含有機溶劑突然缺
所以你看到是什麼台化
什麼都在漲有沒有
石油衍生品 石腦油 製成有沒有看到
目前沒有決定什麼時候恢復訂單有沒有看到
這都有影響到
那我不要講太多時間
我现在讲的是第七期的股票
因为我准备要做多 那没办法
我们到时候就看台积电法术后
我就读一下台积电法术后
看有没有比较好买点
没有 那就是更要买
听懂吗 来来
那我们今天点点名
大家好好久没有直播了
好久没有直播了 我们看一下
因为你们就喜欢跟我互动嘛
看一下大家互动的方式
来 马桶缺料
少赚 偷偷马桶
示範點還是會來
對啊 所以我要做多
我要做多
示範點本來就會來
來
前面的口號
按上面
謝謝大家
愛你
記得輸了
應該說現在錯了
不代表永遠一輩子錯了
好不好
OK
這跟大家講
眼色氣勢好了
來來
來來來
火會被埋在高點
這個換成什麼疾病
就肺結結啦 肺結結啦
肺結結切除啦
來來
火台的錄影算已經算奇蹟了
因為我敷衍能力蠻好的來不是有人說我們台灣是肺葉切除丸果嗎來就是流行做LDCT嘛然後就在一個0.6公分的醫生建議要切除一下
就這麼簡單
來
所以會比較喘
所以大家都要多做健康檢查
台灣第一名的是肺癌
第二名是大腸癌
這些都可以利用健康檢查
視線預防
好不好
來
先我们来看一下
看一下这些
看一下这些东西
所以我要讲就是说
你现在要慢慢的
我们找低基础股票
台湾股票你看
上位指数创新高
台湾股市创历史新高
收盘价
今天创收盘价历史新高
可是很多股票其实很弱
很多股票其实回答很凶
你要注意一下
你看
央行可能Q2可能升息
有没有看到
短期內新台幣31字頭可能成新常態
可是31字頭成新常態代表外資不一定會賄賂
蠻好玩的
你懂不懂
我一定要說蠻好玩的
等一下我會講台積電法說
所以我要講的是說
其實我們可以慢慢找一些低基金股票
或正式噴出
你不要找就是漲很多的股票
比如6770利基電
它漲很多
可是對它現在有點做頭
可是他前陣子
他前陣子涨很多
我宁愿去买南雅科
看明天法说怎么样
今天法说怎么样
因为南雅科这一段
从326跌到200元
其实他等于打大概7折
6折多了
大概符合我们的35法则
就是回转35%
在这边
好不好
这是我要讲的
那00642U
你说泽泽
那原油呢
原油我其实现在赚钱的
赚钱可是他还会不会涨上去
也有可能会继续涨上去
可是涨上去过程中
因為我要做多了你知道嗎
我可能石油
到時候可能考慮石油
然後欣欣 蟬龍 陽明
這些我可能一律都出掉
就是我不做戰爭受惠股
因為我已經講了
戰爭目前為止不影響股市
或許中一天它會影響股市
到時候再說
我不知道等人要等兩個月
三個月 四個月
我等不及了
你懂嗎 我等不及了
所以我的石油是賺錢的
你看今天一天就涨多少%
涨6%
那時候拉回我還說我考慮進場面下
一來一玩也快10%你知道嗎
又快10%
來我們念一下
來來你一定要幫我念一下
好來念一下
4月13號星期一下午1點53特抗簡訊
恭喜00642U
其原大S&P石油ETF
股價跳空大漲超過6%
即將再佔新高
從我們買進到現在
最高已經獲利13%
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續報
所以你看
最高13%
但是最高只有20幾%
我講的是特購委員
如果別人等級會員
有人賺更多好不好
之前賺到30%
從我們推薦到現在30%
我們就很失災
這東西都沒辦法造假
這東西沒辦法造假
所以我打算做多
我只能說
投資沒有
哲哲這次沒有買到最低點
絕對沒有
可是我們就記憶體而已
我們還是出得很漂亮
我要前面的意思是
就記憶體而已
我們出得很漂亮
而且這些績效都實實在在的
就哲哲這次想要造神
但是沒有造神成功
想要造山運動
台灣股市看有沒有做一座山
看來也沒有
那也沒關係
好不好
我們就是
我們就像我剛才講的
之前我看空子
為了賺更多
那現在賺不了
沒關係少賺
之前看空只是为了赚更多
少赚一点没关系
好不好
这跟大家讲
那我也稍微提一下
就是说
这个
其实我不用提了
就是依然的一个识点建议书
反正就是
一个柚的原料
核能的原料
还有和母之海侠
谁管的嘛
你知道吗
最好笑的是
和母之海侠
依然要收钱
川普说我跟你一起收钱
你听懂吗
川普說跟你一起收錢
那這個兩個會不會談很久
當然會談很久啊
為什麼
因為2015年有個伊朗協議
那個時候歐巴馬已經談很久了
川普一上任
2016年2017年就把他撕毀了
然後拜登要跟他重談的時候
談兩年沒有談出一個什麼東西都沒有
所以伊朗比想像中還來得硬啊
那今天川普給他羞辱事的一個談判
人家願意跟他答應他嗎
要答應也不會是一兩天答應
所以油價一定會持續的高漲
油價也持續高漲
只是因為現在AI太厲害了
因為現在AI agents
我剛才特別下載這Enthropic的Cloud
它Cloud的厲害是寫程式
如果是說對話 搜尋資訊這方面的話
我知道最近Enthropic有一個
可以發現各大軟體公司
各大銀行的所有的弊端
你覺得恐不恐怖
恐不恐怖
他在公布之前還告訴財政部
告訴FAD
然後他們把所有人集合起來
所以這個程式可以輕易的
解你們每一個人的bug
可以讓你們所有的APP淡掉
就是可能國泰四華
然後所有的軟體全部淡掉
國泰四華 富邦金控
你不覺得很恐怖
你們所有的APP可以把它淡掉
因為它可以找到你所有軟體的bug的問題
然後輕輕鬆鬆的進入你的頁面
它還沒正式公布
那為什麼沒正式公布
第一個公布完又不得了
第二個
現在記憶體不足啊
現在晶片不足啊
所以台積電今年晶片應該真的不錯啦
你懂嗎
所以這AI agent這一塊
會讓台灣股市真的到4萬點
只是我比較貪心一點
我想讓大家三萬
再兩萬九買
可惜它最低就來到三萬一千多而已
就差那一千多點
那沒關係沒關係
那我還是會來到我要的四萬點
好不好
我趕快
四萬點的時候
我們趕快去借一下它就可以了
好不好
那如果不要等到四萬點
我再做多了
這樣子很可惜
好不好
我們這三六以下
趕快去做個多
好不好
這我跟大家講的
就是我要講的是說
這個已經有人在討論了
就是說
MSOPC這一個新的一個系統
你們不知道沒關係
我再告訴大家跟你講
好不好
那我們來看一下
接下來也有這些東西
接下來有本週的一個市場焦點
來看一下
所以這都很重要
第一個4月16號是什麼
是台積電的法說
4月16號是IBM Intel跟Google的法說
不好意思大哥
喝個水
我一直咳嗽
你們如果做那種廢業切除的就知道
肘子算是無縫接管很厲害了
對
來跟大家講
找術域封他方法不用切
沒關係已經切了
肘子已經切了
切掉什麼後遺症嘛
就是會喘啦
聽到中藝師族的肘子
祝你健康
保重身體
要多做低基電電腦斷層
對
这跟大家
那科各方面看起来不错
看起来那科不错
那我们看那科今天公布
这是最新的新闻怎样
收位毛利来到67.9很高
单季税后经历
每股盈利高达8.4英元
是第一季
所以今年赚个32元
32元也还好
因为现在已经200多元了
好不好
哪哪不然很棒
别再砍楼
很多人在剪套勞
套勞是套勞的
套勞
我觉得
感觉很多人在讲哪科
不知道是因为你被套住
还怎么样
OK
爱你哦
谢谢大家
我也爱大家
好不好
来来来
这跟大家
这点名什么辙的
不用拿
我这次讲错
一定有別的頭顧一定會講我
可是我覺得我都不在乎
他們怎麼講
你只要記得一件事情
會批評分析師的分析師
就是不務正業
就這樣就好了
就是這樣子就好了
好不好
你只要記得一件事情
會批評分析師的分析師
基本上他們都不敢參加全國比賽
從以前到現在
我發現這是定論的
那你要記得
會批評分析師的分析師
業績不會太好
就這麼簡單
其他我都不必多說了
那我只要承認我這次是錯了
所以我就錯了
所以他們要批評隨便他們
好不好
可是至少我敢去做這個賭注啊
是不是
哲哲可以祝我生日快樂嗎
我看一下
我不知道怎麼稱呼你耶
那個GG毛
loveGG
4月9號生日啦
好不好
OK
4月9號生日
OK OK
謝謝你
這看起來真的很喘
我記得你算状況最好的一一沒錯吧對不對對我昨天去走個3公里昨天前天去走個三公里走完以後馬上睡著
馬上睡著
車上睡著
昏迷不醒
可是感覺變瘦
沒有我沒有變瘦
我沒有變瘦
變胖了
好啦
清明節不賣股
年節後來撿股
對不好意思
就最近沒有對啦
好啦
隨便你們調侃啦
隨便你們調侃
這最近就沒有對
沒關係沒關係
我現在都看得比較輕鬆一點
沒有對就沒有對 能怎麼辦
所以被他調侃我也覺得接受啦
我也覺得接受
來
當然有沒有可能
這幾天跌下來讓我剪一下
就看老天閃不閃鏈啦好不好
不過我已經跟你講
台積電這個晶片不錯
但是有人講台積電最新的法說
那為什麼這個行情很好
為什麼說好到不行
來 我們那時候不是說CPI3.3嗎
結果美國禮拜五還是漲啊
肺炮還是漲啊
最棒創新高啊还是涨啊
你听懂吗
所以它现在利空也涨
利多也涨
台湾股市最夸张啊
你看台湾股市你看一下这边
台湾股市跟高档只差0.3%
日本股市跟高档
跟历史高点还差5%
台湾股市差了快10%
这10%差很多
快9.4%
你看一个9%的话
跟台灣股市差大概2700點
台灣股市如果跟韓國股市距離高點的話
是9.4%的話
那台灣股市現在要先吐個
呃
大概
吐個3000點耶
要先吐個3000點你聽懂嗎
你懂我來說什麼嗎
Do you know what I mean
來我們看一下
其實我今天
我今天能直播我也覺得蠻奇蹟的
在今天之前我還在覺得
我到底要不要直播
我自己還不知道
我們給你看一下
動一下
你看
台灣股市就是要創新高
離新高根本就一下子嘛對不對
韓國股市離新高
還有一陣子有沒有看到
台灣之前跟韓國股市現在不跟了
利不厲害
台灣股市之前跟日本股市現在不跟了
日本股市離新高看還有一段距離有沒有看到
台灣股市離新高一樣的距離有沒有看到
這差不多了
所以今天平地值新高收盤價平地值新高
韓國股市到這邊還有一段距離有沒有看到
怪貌指數先創新高利不厲害
好厲害
我们继续看下去哦
肺斑指数
台湾股市跟肺斑指数串
可是肺斑指数前阵子根本没串新高
你看啊
很好玩哦
这样看就知道了
你看肺斑指数在这边是不是打底打底
台湾股市这边自己涨啊
自己串新高要对不对
继续串新高啊
這邊是跟著韓國股市走
利不厲害
這邊那時候我就說
我要稍微保守一點點有沒有
這邊是跟著韓國股市走
這邊是跟著非半指數走
媽媽咪啊
你看非半指數這時候沒有創新高啊
台灣股市正式創新高
一個台積電你看
納斯達克很弱
因為現在軟體太多bug了
我一個anthropic的一個模型
就全部打敗人軟體
寫著一些程式
但這個
我剛剛用Enthropic
我在用Cloud
在用一次
確定它
你们可以不用用呢
就是你们不太会写程式的
认为逻辑不太好的
就算你
或者你不太会写程式的
我觉得不用去下载Cloud
蛮烂的
我讲烂的是说
B2C这一块
企业对消费者这一块
蛮烂的
企业对企业这一块
或者你會寫程式人
你要下來cloud
如果不會寫的話
你不用下載了
好吧 我覺得cloud不好用
這跟大家講
他太及時的消息都不太好用
好啦 我們先休息一下好了好不好
我們先休息一下
怎樣跟大家講
更多台股秘密
休息一下忙回來
每天說賺錢
我是星期日報
選股冠軍記錄保持者
也是全台灣LINE
以及Telegram粉絲人數
最多的分析師
郭哲聰投資長
如果你想要找一位
在深夜美股崩盤的時候
仍然堅持發送
免費最新文章
清晨醒來
就能為你獨家解析
美股財報
以及小豆腐指數
為何波動這麼大
甚至想找尋在台股衝破一萬三千點之前
就一切預告在前的分析師
那恭喜你找對人了
標股人人都會喊
但兼具天分、勇氣、誠信、獨立的分析師
全台灣只有我一位
我是郭哲隆
歡迎加入全台灣最大的財經分析師頻道
讓我帶你一起進場賺大錢
好 所以台灣股是真人厲害喔
所以一定要看台積電的一個法說
我們先來看一下台積電法說
這還是很認真研究
你不認對我錯
那說實話
你說姐姐
這個是會不會
會不會怎麼樣
會不會被懲罰到
一定會啊
我點閱率一定會下滑
這一定會啦
當然鐵粉還是會喜歡我
可是我點閱率一定會下滑
一定會
譬如說我來個十幾萬的人
看我節目嘛
你至少會打個九折
打個九折至少會少個一萬一兩萬
所以這個就最好懲罰了
說實話好不好
但可是問題是就有會員而已
我們都會還是相信我
因為就像我們講的
他們只是覺得少賺
也不一定覺得少賺
如果一開始從頭到尾買紅海
他們現在是多賠
是多賠
我先跟大家講
那有些人就覺得說
只能至少講在前面
至少沒有騙人
很多人是願意相信我
也謝謝你們
來
我們來看一下
所以你們找我
至少我
你看我不認得
有沒有生病怎麼樣
我一定都最努力的
跟大家解這個盤勢
台積法說大謀推演三情境
有沒有看到
有悲观情境还有基本情境
基本情境就是营收计真大概5到10%
这边有办法很大
5到10%有办法
然后毛利率是64到65
然后营收财测大于10%
其实我觉得大概就差不多10%
差不多8到10%
差不多
8到10%
他应该跟你讲说8到10%
这边
64到65
我觉得有可能大于65
这跟大家讲
好不好
地缘紧张与非AI微浮影响
这后续涨
我觉得介于这两者之间
基本跟乐观
因为华尔街太缺晶片了
你听懂吗
好来
然后EPS
他说EPS
他说今年2022年EPS
本来有说88元
所以今年有可能95到100
这也是为什么台积电
现在可以到2000元
可通常要注意一下
注意一下
说明年120到240
可是你真的要注意一下是
2000元20倍本益比
台积电本益比也算高了
你等于把明年EPS算进去了
所以台积电
说老实话
如果台积電再漲到2100、2100
基本上你已經把明年EP算進去了
這不一定有利於台股
所以為什麼說4萬點
4萬點差不多
你去算一下喔
台積電如果今年到下半年的時候
2400等於把明年EP算進去了
是
多400元嘛
台積電多400元嘛
現在大概2000元嘛
多400元乘上一個台積電多少
一點台積電大概貢獻台股大概
1元台積電在貢獻台股大概8點嘛
那3600加3000
加3200多少
刚好差不多4万点
因为其他股票还是会涨嘛
所以为什么我预测台湾股市今年4万点
你会觉得很恐怖
所以为什么我说
台湾50很多问我台湾50
什么时候都可以买
你也可以等我那时候2900的时候买
只是买不到而已
真是买不到
真不好意思
所以我要告诉大家
如果是2027年的EPS来说
用20倍本一比的话
台积电2400
大概就差不多是4万点
所以我看了4万点
你要反映明年的EPS
至少要下半年
然后上半年
上半年也可以
那就变得有点泡沫了
所以为什么
我说今天台湾股市
是有机会4万点的
这件事
因为多这20元的EPS
120元的EPS
乘上20倍本益比是2400元
比现在多400元比现在多400元的话1元贡献台湾股市8点等于8430等于贡献3200点那现在都要3600
加3200点
不是快要4万点了吗
其他股市一定会一起拉高的
好不好
这样懂我来说什么
所以重点是
今年EPS你觉得
有没有可能95到100
第一个资本支出有没有增加
财测有没有增加
可是我讲的都已经
有没有可能礼拜四礼拜五
利多出去你要注意一下好不好
注意一下注意一下
通膨这个还是要注意一下
先记在这个脑海里面
那最后我讲一个小故事给大家听
就这个
这个是我小时候就看到大家
一个蛮喜欢的一个主播
这无安琪
我讲就是说
其实现在就是网路化了
TBS不是要裁员吗
打100人
媒体世界打100人算很多
资深主播跟基层员工
全部打了
然後這吳安琪主播聽說他被裁員的時候
通知日是4月12號 你們知道
聽說他一氣之下把他的獎盃全部丟掉
那這個人講話很得體喔
他說沒有關係
他說我最佳風雨你主持人
好像56歲 57歲了
手機網路票選主播金鐘甲
美國紐約州雪城大雪館電措施
難怪我們公司之前
莉莉不是有遇到議會嗎
之前是中式單家主播
我就說主持人 主播不好單 有沒有
是
好 那這個就優秀 優秀
可是他在錯的道路上
我不是要批評他
我說沒辦法 要是我是他
我四五十歲
我那時候要是我也不想走
你懂嗎
所以我覺得有時候人有痛苦
沒什麼不好
太順遂 可是你在錯誤的道路上
你在努力也沒有用
你現在電視台就沒有人在看啊
電視台就沒有人在看
我覺得很好玩
我之前遇到一些老師說
哲哲 我要買節目
我問你買什麼節目
買哪個頻道節目
我就問你 那你會看這個頻道嗎
不會看 我就想買節目
那都是比較老的前輩
我這樣不要講誰 不只一位
就錯誤的觀念
重點是觀眾是多少
所以我要講的是說
第二件事情
這個跟你們沒有關係
我要講的是說
你們要再對著道路
第二件事情是說
今天你各個各位都有可能
在AI的時代被淘汰
你被淘汰的時候
你是不是要有一技資產
投資啊
你只要會投資
你不怕被淘汰
你看連一個TVB是單家的主播
我從小看到到一個靜然的主持人
可是他實不我已
網路他的興起也造成魔鬼頭故
現在很強大
可是有人強大就有人
有人受益就有人受害嘛
傳統電視台就有人受害啦
像除了我爸媽看第四台
我周遭朋友沒有人看第四台
就算你要看TVPS
你也透過YouTube看
你不是透過第四台看
它就是個趨勢
可是趨勢十年前他就知道
一樣啊
我常常跟很多工程師講
比如說哇
你是粘電工程師
你可以買台積電啊
你台積電工程師
你可以買納斯達克的ETF啊
你幹嘛全部裡面
你把你人生押注在同一個東西裡面
你可以選擇
你不一定
你現在男
以前說女怕嫁錯男
男怕入錯男
當然我不要說女生這一塊
現在好像變成
我好像瞧不起女生
不是
男生最怕入錯男的
尤其中年的時候
那你現在你要一個
你要一個投資的一季
一季
要一季資產
不懂沒關係
你可以看我的節目
或者你想要更多
你可以參加我會員
你聽得懂嗎
我是看到連TBS都要賣掉了
我就覺得哇塞
真的很誇張
你知道嗎真的很誇張你知道嗎
然後有關後續細節
這個要裁員已經不止了
之前南部的也有說要裁啊
怎麼樣TBS南部要裁
所以兩波裁員名單
這看起來是裁真的
但有可能被賣掉
可以被賣掉也沒有用啊
你懂嗎
被賣掉你除非要網路化
就它有個牌子
可是你TBS要全力的網路化
如果電視台化的話那是沒有用的
你聽得懂嗎
所以我要講的是說
如果你今天不認識主播
或者你是任何職位
any job
你是任何的工作
你一定要除了工作以外
我就要保護你最好的地方
是會投資
一定要會投資
好不好
選擇對的股票會投資
那這對你來說是不錯的
好不好
會投資
你看今天我們今天就石油而已
有人賺30%
有人賺40%
石油還在漲啊
是不是
你看我们卖掉红海油
它还在跌啊
是不是
那我们再逢低200元以下再买
可不可以
可以啊
你听懂吧
或者是管达
看起来它也要拉起来
那是不是
是不是等它拉回的时候
看起来就
在第二波高中期的时候
我们进场
可以啊
1000多张股票
你可以从整整这边学到很多东西
国具看起来正式喷出了
也可以找一个机会买进它
可以啊 你懂吗
日月关日月投控
有没有看到
今天至于喷出 有没有看到
很多股票它是有机会正式喷出的
你不要觉得不可能你知道吗
那封测的历程看起来也是有点
跌得有点可惜你知道吗
所以我都尽量预告在前面
我都说有些股票
你找回弹比较深的股票
联发科也是一样啊
回弹比较深啊
1975這給你殺下去
奇怪台機電給你拉起來了
這邊給你殺下去
他也跟Google AI晶片有關係
為什麼他不能買
可以啊
1000多檔你學會一劑之
一劑之產的時候
你不怕被人家取代
所以你真的認同我講這句話
不論你是中年了
怕失業或者你現在已經退休了
你想轉更多
你可以來找姊姊啊
你會發現到姊姊不論有沒有生病
你會發現到
我還是
但是我會讓你看到我是最認真的我
我會看到永遠是100分的我
我會看到100分努力的我
有時候會有100分的績效不一定
有時候會有200分的績效
那時候績效很好啊
可是我要講的是說
等我整得更好的時候
更順的時候
我有信心績效更好
我有信心績效更好好不好
那今天我也不多說
我今天起我單充有少賺
但是有小賺一點點
小賺那個70點
但是這個70點真的不算多
我整個期貨的績效不太好
可是股票績效我是有信心
接下來我要賺一段
像萊亞科一樣200%
像星星一樣賺160%
像景碩一樣賺120%
像星權一樣賺100多%
這些實實在在的績效
我想要努力來幫大家賺好不好
那今天就看台積電的法說
那台灣股市已經是非常非常強大
雖然強大到我覺得
籌碼有點亂
但是我們得要尊重趨勢
趨勢就是這樣子
這就預告在前面
可則不論是對或錯
我是一切一切意高到前面
今天從TVBS的財源
我希望大家學到一個理念
什麼理念
永遠要備胎
永遠要備案
你要學位投資
當自己的主人
所以認同我這一句話的時候
歡迎來電下行
080668085
或加我LINE私訊我
不論怎麼樣
今天台灣股市
就是有機會要4萬點
可則少賺1千沒關係
但最後一段 最肥的一段
我會努力撞到它
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝各位 明天見 掰掰
如果觉得我们影片很有趣的
觉得有深度的
还蛮准确的
欢迎按赞我们的影片
订阅我们的影片
按小铃铛
记得按全部接收
还要加我们的LINE
以及加我们的Telegram
我们的LINE跟Telegram
都是全台湾最大的一个财经频道
谢谢各位
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家